child care services in havana will soon
become more affordable to many families
across the valley governor steve sisilak
and other state officials expanding the
fund to pay for child care with some 50
million dollars madison kimbrough
joining us live in our newsroom madison
has those details the cost of child care
is always a topic of discussion among
parents and with these added funds it
will help cover child care co-pays for
those using state subsidized child care
programs
here in nevada chelsea slider works for
the children's cabinet a non-profit
organization that works closely with the
las vegas urban league to offer a
variety of child care services for
southern nevada families services like
child care subsidy and child care
resource referrals whereas the
children's cabinet offers emergency and
infant toddler grants family counseling
and parent education and support slider
says with this boost in funds there's a
whole new group of families who will now
be able to receive support we see people
every day come through our doors that
are
barely making it or they're not making
ends meet you know they're barely
getting by so this is going to provide a
huge amount of financial
stress relief for our families so that
they could go to work and
focus on that and know that their
children are in a high quality
learning environment the program
provided child care help for low income
families who make around 36 thousand
dollars per year and now governor
sisalek says with this extra money
relief is now expanded to those in the
middle income range of up to 70 thousand
dollars per year per family
and for families and providers
interested in the program here in
southern nevada you can head to the
website you see on your screen that's
childcarelv.org
according to governor sisil act the hope
is that these funds will last through
20-23 in the newsroom madison kimbrough
live local now